and just between 2020 into 2021 um we've
hit our highest number in a year yet for
deaths and that was around 90 000. so
the opioid crisis is just
just uh a perfect storm of worse
proportions that has really um
hurt so many not just with addiction but
also overdoses and all the many problems
that come with those struggles
it's like whoa i'm in a lot of pain like
i fall on having autoimmune disorder a
guy like i'm there's a reason i need
these painkillers and at the moment it's
the difference between being in chronic
pain and not sleeping and then depending
on a pain medication later that i'm
going to have to get off of because
they're dependents forming and some of
them say look for whatever reason i
can't manage this on my own so i'll be
on this medication and the analogy and
medically this is not the right analogy
but um metaphorically um insulin might
be the right analogy you know it's just
a medication you need to take every day
um other people do get off but it's
usually unless you've been uh had a drug
problem for a short period of time you
typically have to be on these uh
replacement medications for a while and
the reason is because it takes a long
time to repair your life
welcome to the michaela pearson podcast
episode 127.
in this episode sally setel and peter
pishka joined me for a conversation
about dependence forming medications
the opioid crisis in america and their
connection to the system for
prescription meds in the u.s
this episode was close to my heart
because i had chronic pain for 10 years
ankle replacement hip replacement
arthritis and getting pain medication
was very difficult in a very dangerous
way
this is one of those topics i think
everyone should be aware of
sally is a psychiatrist and addiction
medicine writer she's a lecturer at yale
school of medicine then the author of
pcmd how political correctness is
corrupting medicine
more recently she co-authored
brainwashed the seductive appeal of
mindless neuroscience her articles have
been published in the new york times the
new republic and the wall street journal
peter's a journalist focused on health
and disability issues he hosts the happy
warrior podcast and has appeared on many
top podcasts and tv shows one of his
most famous articles is titled a painful
struggle opioids can be dangerous but
restrictions or a ban
are worse
as a journalist who struggled with
chronic pain himself he aims to inform
people about far-reaching issues like
the opioid epidemic our main focus in
this episode
if you enjoyed this or at least learn
something please remember to hit
subscribe
[Music]
sally satell and peter pinchke thank you
for joining me on the podcast uh before
we get started
can i get you guys to give a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you do let's start with peter
hi well it's great to be here on the
podcast thank you for having me on my
name is peter pischke
i am a health journal and disability
reporter i write and speak a lot on the
issues of the opioid crisis
um
medical ethics i talk a lot about the
issues facing disabled americans and of
course chronic pain patients that's
really where i found the law of success
talking about what's happening
with uh pain patients but you know other
patients that require pain uh medicine
such as you know someone with a cancer
or a terminal illness
um and speaking to the issues of their
concerns in particular what i refer to
as the prescription opioid prohibition
and how that affects uh so many millions
and has created a situation
that is so much harder than it already
was and the opioid crisis is
already an extremely difficult thing i
also do um my own podcast substance
happy warrior and i'm just really
glad to be here today thank you
sweet okay sally
i'm a psychiatrist and
i'm also a resident
a fellow with the american enterprise
institute which is a think tank in
washington dc and i've worked
seems forever in methadone clinics where
by definition
folks who come in there have
a problem with opioids
in inner cities it's mainly heroin i i
worked for a year in a small town in
ohio and there
um
pills were a bigger problem although
even at that time which was 2018 there
was already a transition to
heroin and fentanyl even methamphetamine
was coming in there but so
that's my
credentials for knowing about opioids
and in the course of studying the opioid
crisis i study many many things but
that's one of them
and um and i became aware
as well of the uh problems facing
chronic pain patients because we've just
uh swung the pendulum so far in the
other direction about being afraid of
painkillers which can
literally be lifesavers that that's
created yet another problem
okay fantastic i wanted to bring you
guys on here because i've got
i would say extend an extensive
background in painkillers from having my
hip and ankle replaced and just having
arthritis i've been on
opiates a number of times and gotten off
of them and experienced withdrawal but
i've also experienced what happened to
my life when i wasn't able to get
painkillers fast enough which led to
being
suicidal fairly quickly because i
couldn't sleep
so i wanted to bring you guys on to give
the audience a bit of a background on
i wouldn't say i don't want to say like
the benefits of painkillers but why
they're necessary for some people
especially people living in chronic pain
the dangers associated with taking them
or with not being able to get them
but
um
where do we want to start
can
can you guys give a brief background
about
what happened to start this
opioid
crisis
um i guess if that's okay with uh sally
i'll start there so uh the opioid crisis
uh there are several arguments about
where it's beginning but the most common
one or side one
is that following on most 20th century
which was uh basically anti-opioid
there's something called opioid phobia
you can see this in old tv shows and
movies in the 1990s things started to
change there was a bigger emphasis on
trying to get
pain care to more people and that in
total pain care in many places and
sometimes i was taken too far in the
1990s we had the invention of oxycontin
which was a
pain medication opioid and it was
its use was to be for long-term chronic
pain because you need to stretch it out
across your day so there's more medicine
in it
the company that put it out purdue they
heavily mismarketed the drug they made
claims about that just weren't true and
the drug rep sold it incredibly hard at
the same time we had the federal
government who was pushing very heavily
for a
policy we would later call the fifth
vital sign which was we have to for our
individual patient we have to get
complete and total control of their pain
we're going to take doctors and we're
going to put their metrics against how
much pain they can get on top of so they
went from
very little pain killers for people that
really need it to too many painkillers
for everybody and there was some
irresponsibility there there is some
argument that
americans have drug problems before this
we can we'll definitely get into that
but anyhow that kind of got the the
addiction side of it especially in
places like sally uh worked in in ohio
industrial places in the country where
you have people working heavy intensive
labor jobs so they have a higher rate of
injury and they need some kind of
painkiller to get on with their life and
we were seeing issues sometimes where it
was sometimes referred to as hillbilly
heroin they could take this drug
oxycontin and it could kind of be like
heroin on the cheap they would mix it
with water become gel-like
put it in
and inject
um and that was a major problem
the deaths part though that's the part
that's when people noticed this issue
going on did you really get going until
2011 when the us government uh the obama
administration stepped in and required
purdue to reform the oxycontin so
couldn't be turned into that gel-like
substance
and by doing that they took all these
people who are using a relatively safe
supply drug though unwisely and they
they push them to black market drugs and
much more dangerous substances and then
as that got going um illicit fentanyl
which in the normal medical setting is
an incredible drug that makes surgery
and all kinds of amazing modern medical
miracles possible
but uh as an illicit drug is extremely
dangerous it is very very potent and so
all of a sudden we have these people who
are casually using these drugs and
struggling with addiction and we push
them on to
um lethal substances and that's kind of
what got all the deaths going um 500 000
or so over the last decade and just
between 2020 into 2021 um we've hit our
highest number in a year yet for deaths
and that was around 90 000. so the
opioid crisis is just
just uh a perfect storm of worst worst
proportions that has really
hurt so many not just with addiction but
also overdoses and all the many problems
that come with those struggles
okay so you said 90 000 deaths between
2020 and 2021 yeah from 2019 so you go
into 20 and then 2020 into 20 21. yeah
okay and how far above that
does that have anything to do with a
pandemic and an increase in an opiate
disc from like maybe depression
it's a little hard definitely the
pandemic does feed it some but we're
already seeing a high uptick
in the uh the number of deaths before
the pandemic started um so the pandemic
definitely played a part but it's hard
to it's hard like to take these strands
and tear them apart and tell totally
which is which
but they were both definitely a heavy
factor
and the strategies that we've used so
far to try to deal with the opioid
crisis um when it comes how the
heavy-handedness to pain patients and
others
has not worked in fact there are many
studies that just came out this year
this summer even that show that when we
take people who are relying on opioid
pain medications and we force taper them
we take them off the medications against
their will it pushes them into a spiral
a very dangerous situation what you
yourself talked about and myself i went
through back in 2018 when i was
forcibly removed from my medications
from a physician that i trusted
that can be a very dangerous situation
for patients and that has only fed into
the amount of overdose deaths and the
deaths of despair
it's a horrible horrible situation
just awful
okay um do you mind touching on what
happened to you what you went through
yeah that's fine um so i have i'm a
full-time disabled person uh up 14 years
ago this october of just this month um i
came down with chronic pancreatitis um
that has developed in some other health
issues and i was reliant on tramadol and
oxycontin to be able to meet my pain
needs wasn't the most effective once it
wasn't the super best but it did its job
i was able to go and get my bachelor's
and later my master's i was um active in
my local area i ran for school board one
year that was an interesting experience
so i had a somewhat active wife's you
know pretty good pretty good compared to
many and then unfortunately um the push
against opioids had finally caught up
with my town here in south dakota my
physician pushed put me aside one day
she says look i only have two patients
left on opioids it's you and this gal
with ms and
i i like you guys but i don't
necessarily think this is really good
for you and so i'm trying to get all my
patients off of opioids there's a little
bit of victim blaming and a little bit
of like i want to protect my license you
know
i'm doing this for my own good as much
as yours
uh but it was uh it was a very heavy
thing at the time i was teaching public
school
and i remember getting off the phone
after trying to talk them through this
and make my case and just feeling like i
just don't know how i'm gonna go on do i
just do it is suicide the option now
pete
it was very dark situation
um
thank god you know i was um the lord
really held my hand helped me get
through that and now my my health
difficulties have only many of them have
gone worse because of that untreated
pain issue but i still have tremble from
another physician i was able to find so
i'm luckier than most
and i fell into this journalism thing
again which i went to school for so i've
had a pretty pretty good situation
compared to many people but the many
people i've talked to personally either
through my reporting or advocacy as
friends and family i mean they can take
things that maybe you would someone else
would think that's a relatively little
thing like someone gets a knee surgery
the knee replacement surgery and you
know they're just it's just a knee
replacement surgery like why aren't you
stepping out of it but the untreated
pain gets out of control and can take
over their lives and you can take
someone that has an issue with pain
medicine you can relatively give them a
full
normal active life and you push them on
essentially to disabled one and that is
that's such a common story that is all
over the place
um and it's it's a wide range of people
that are required on pain medication
either for short-term situations like a
surgery sometimes for long-term and the
most disturbing
is and it's with a terminal illness and
even though many people many people know
that doctors know that this is ethically
wrong they also their hospital system or
the state medical board might come down
on them and so they have to make a a
hard decision when you're dealing with
someone that might you know have
metastasizing third stage lung cancer
and you're like they'll literally say
this and i've heard this so many times
it's almost it's really hard to believe
you'll say things like i don't want to
get you addicted
it's like
my mom is in her 80s she's dying from
lung cancer this is not this is not a
concern of ours right now doc but
unfortunately
um dark humor sorry for laughing
what else do you do common story i've
heard
yeah
yeah
uh
my experience i guess with opiates is so
i needed my hip and ankle replaced and i
started not being able to sleep so
because i couldn't put my hip in in a
position i was 17. couldn't put my hip
in a position that didn't hurt enough
that i stopped sleeping and i went to my
rheumatologist and
she said have you tried ibuprofen
and i was like at that point i was
basically walking on broken bones and i
was like yeah we've tried ibuprofen like
i can't sleep
and she'd had a bad experience with a
previous patient a kid who had gone on
opiates and hadn't gotten off of them
easily and so she just stopped
prescribing them so she referred us to a
pain clinic and the weight wait look
wait time was six weeks
and at that point i was considering
suicide because of the pain
and so that was when i first got clued
in to
it's like whoa i'm in a lot of pain like
i fall on having autoimmune disorder i
got like i'm there's a reason i need
these painkillers and at the moment it's
the difference between being in chronic
pain and not sleeping and then depending
on a pain medication later that i'm
going to have to get off of because
they're dependents forming but
you have to weigh the costs and benefits
and i feel like society's kind of gone
in this direction where it's like oh if
you have an addiction or a dependence on
something
that is the worst thing that can happen
even if the alternative is you know
living in chronic pain which is
completely unacceptable sally what what
kind of people
did you see um in methadone clinics when
you were working there was it a wide
range or was it a specific
subset of people what did it look like
oh i still work there um well these are
always in their city uh mainly
washington dc
and there you see largely what i call
old school addicts um these are um in
inner cities they tend to be um
black uh men and women now the average
age in our clinic is 57
they started using a long time ago when
heroin was weaker
a lot of them start
with injecting because it was weaker
you know many of them have had hiv and
hepatitis c
and um
you know we occasionally get some young
people uh who tend to be more white and
uh they've
the story with them is they've often
tried bubinorphine suboxone
and while it helps a lot of people it
just didn't help them and that's why
they came to methadone because the trend
now is to refer
um uh people who are you know first
coming in for an opioid problem to uh
excuse me to put them on suboxone which
is uh unlike methadone i guess i should
explain you know methadone is been
around since the 60s
and it's what's called it um an opioid
replacement it is an opioid it's it's
synthetic
um and uh
it really it takes the place of the
heroin or take the place of the
oxycodone or um
whatever opioid you're on uh
buprenorphine is a medication that
doesn't completely it's complicated
medication doesn't completely
um replace uh
let me just say that at lower doses it's
more of a replacement and higher doses
um
it gets um
it doesn't function that way
but um at higher doses in other words
one becomes um
you know more tolerant to its effects so
that's a built-in protection to overdose
and because of that
uh the federal government has allowed
physicians to prescribe it out of their
office
whereas methadone you must come to a
federally registered methadone clinic
the methadone itself probably costs two
cents a day but there's um the cost of
running the clinics it's pretty high
because you have to have so much
protection it's
investigated and um um supervised by the
dea and also um
samhsa substance abuse mental health
services administration so it's easier
to go to a doctor and get bubinorphine
um
the problem is that um a lot of primary
care doctors and i have to say i do not
blame them because they haven't been
trained
and that's
you hear this story a lot people will go
to a primary care doctor uh
understandably it's very hard to get
into a pain clinic and sometimes you
don't know you need a pain clinic
because you're at the early stages of a
pain condition and um but doctors are uh
you know they're in their private office
and they're not in sort of ensconced in
a methadone clinic with counselors and
um you know a literal plan you know a
literal place where we sometimes have
even uh folks security they're not
thrust to security but you know these
places get a little rough sometimes
they're they're in their office with
patients who are drug problems they
haven't been taught in medical school a
residency how to treat them
there are
lots of myths about
folks who are addicted
uh which is to say that they'll rip you
off
they'll scare the other patients at the
clinic
because they're unkempt or they might
smell bad and i'll i'll tell you um that
can happen but a lot of folks um who who
uh
younger people especially have probably
started buprenorphine on the street so
by the time they come in would come into
a primary care
doctor they're already kind of stable
and they just want the doctor to
prescribe it legitimately and and those
would be easier patients plus they
should be referred to counseling as well
um so
so there's a almost in way two different
cultures of um
uh medicating folks there's the
methadone clinic um we have counselors
they're excellent we have group therapy
people are on these medications for a
while some are on it frankly their whole
life
and those are people who have tried to
get off it um
you know relapsed and uh gone back into
a you know hellscape of addiction and
then come back to the clinic and then
they think they could try it again and
some of them say look for whatever
reason i can't manage this on my own so
i'll be on this medication and the
analogy
and medically this is not the right
analogy but um metaphorically um insulin
might be the right analogy you know it's
just a medication you need to take every
day um other people do get off but it's
usually unless you've been uh had a drug
problem for a short period of time you
typically have to be on these uh
replacement medications for a while and
the reason is because it takes a long
time to repair your life
um
people use drugs for reasons
um i won't prolong talk too long about
this but i think one of the
misunderstandings is that
people sort of just get addicted as in
the accidental addict i've heard that
phrase and i think it's very
useful which is to say you go to a
doctor
and he gives you some percocet for a
toothache and i will certainly agree
that doctors have been far too generous
in the old days with these medications
to give you a month worth you really
only need two days worth um that's a big
problem those pills often got diverted
but um but the
it is not common for people to get
addicted to pain medication that they're
prescribed there are conditions under
which that happens there's no question
typically people with histories of
addiction or current problems with
anxiety or depression those folks are at
risk doesn't mean the doctor shouldn't
prescribe it but he has to be very aware
of those risks and some don't ask
um but you know the myth is that
you know folk i think we're going to see
this on the hulu show
honestly uh called dope sick um
cycles so many of the myths about opioid
addiction uh which is that everyone's at
great risk from getting um percocet or
oxycontin from their doctor
and and they're just not but that myth
led to this this uh
radical radical um retrenchment on
prescribing that was a machete and not a
scalpel and um and it's caused awful
problems for people and um i guess i'll
just finally say that that one of the
many um factors that uh you know gets
lost in all this is when you look at the
overdoses
that that have oxycontin or
oxycodone they won't have the brand in
it you know of course you will have
hydrocodone and oxycodone um
parody and other things like that but um
fentanyl
usually not medical fentanyl this is
illicit fennel um these deaths have
benzos uh valium type drugs yeah xanax
people rarely uh when you look at the
autopsies it's rarely a single drug
problem
yeah one of the comments i want to make
on that so i did a lot of research
because my dad became dependent on
benzodiazepines and it was a
it almost killed him it was complete
disaster uh
but
when i did research when i was looking
into overdoses specifically opiate
overdoses specifically uh most of the
overdoses if not all of the overdoses
i've seen weren't actually just opiates
which is interesting because in
mainstream media you see oh opiate
overdose or something like that but most
of those people are also on
benzodiazepines or some sort of psyched
but alcohol yeah so that's very
interesting um which is something i
didn't know so in the states for
prescribing say
you're in chronic pain and you go to a
doctor are they not allowed to prescribe
something like
oxycontin anymore or oxycodone like or
do you have to be referred to a pain
clinic how does it work in the states
um unfortunately it's a situation where
there's just enough regulation that it
makes it very difficult for a prescriber
to take on that burden at the same time
it says it's left undefined enough so
it's left in the ethers it's not really
well answered
the cdc really pushed this heavily with
the opioid prohibition of things with
the 2016 cd cc guidelines which was an
attempt if you're putting in if you're
looking at the best light was trying to
provide guidance for
um your your general gen your basic
general practitioner about when or when
not to prescribe opioids to people
unfortunately the states special state
medical boards the hospital systems they
took the cdc guidelines and the cc had
never previously had an opinion on this
issue because they're the cdc that's not
their deal that's the fda's deal
but so people took it seriously as law
and in so many states there are 36
states i think now that have laws based
on their guidelines about the arbitrary
90 mme threshold which is morphe milgram
equivalent so that's a topic unto itself
but no often there isn't a law that says
you're not allowed to prescribe this
what happens is and i'll give you a
fantastic example dr roger cho who's a
pretty uh he seems like a decent uh
doctor and scientist he's the one that
was a main primary author on the 2016 cc
guidelines there was a meeting what was
it maybe last year then 2019 where the
cc is meeting and he talks about his
experiences he says you know i have my
patients they come in they need to
prescribe a pain medicine so i prescribe
them a pain medication i then receive a
letter from my state medical board and
hospital system that says you cannot
prescribe this many medicines to this
person because of the the 2016 cc
guidelines and then they'll cite a paper
and it will have his name on it and
and
you see situations like that all the
time it it
often it doesn't have to be you need
enough formal legislation so you can't
do this it's enough for your hospital
system to be aware that this is the way
things are going and this is what
expected they'll keep an eye on you it's
enough that your local law enforcement
or even sometimes federal law
enforcement like dea is putting pressure
on physicians or the hospitals and of
course have the state medical boards
they don't want to cause any problems
and it's it's it's this perfect storm of
uh dissent disincentives at the same
time we are pushing all the you know
if by the way michaela so sorry for the
stuff that you and your dad went through
i remember particularly with your dad
how
cruel and just grossly unfair many
people were being i mean that's typical
i guess of the news and social media
these days
they don't understand part of the
problem is is that we've taken all these
patients you say you we can't trust you
with pain medications if you want to get
some kind of
pain care you have to go to a pain
specialist and so what happens is i'll
then okay so all these patients they
move over to the pain specialist maybe
they were on a painkiller so then
they're put on some other kind of drug
like gabapentin um yeah maybe an
antidepressant a benzodiazepine and uh
two things happen when they do this the
first is that the the the
law enforcement and others look at and
say hey this guy has a much higher level
of prescribing well of course he does
you've taken all the high-risk patients
you gave them to him and the second is
as patients are pushed from one
medication to another eventually that
other medication gets targeted as well
and you so you end up with situations
like in the uk with the nice guidelines
where they're like yeah you can't really
use anything for pain not even
paracetamol
like tylenol
you could maybe do antidepressants and
talk therapy what and that
well because
based on their reasoning those are the
only things that have straight evidence
the other stuff is too risky but
it's a crazy situation if you have any
experience dealing with pain those those
strategies really work in a desperate
situation so it it it's crazy we've
created a situation that's that's up in
the air enough that no one really wants
to answer for it and patients are left
to learn if you've ever been to your
physician trying to figure out a problem
you go to visit to visit to visit you do
the test and eventually you come to a
point where there are no more tests you
can get there aren't my answers and then
so then your physician is like
and you're just kind of like left in
there well it's kind of like that for so
many patients their inability to get
their pain treated seriously is an issue
of unfortunately medical or moral apathy
it's it's awful it's a terrible
situation for so many and
who knows how long this thing is going
to go on
yeah
well yeah you mentioned um
peter the 2016 guidelines from the cdc
and you know if you look at them
they were intended for primary care docs
and it was called you know high-dose
opioid prescribing and paraphrasing a
little bit but you know intended for
primary care docs
and some may quibble but i think the
guidelines really weren't that bad i
mean they had some basic good
information which is if you if you are
going to use opioids so the assumption
right there is that they have some value
um you have to start at a low dose or
you should they're guidelines they don't
have the force of law start low and the
phrase is go slow so if you do have to
raise the dose you know do it slowly
um
and some other points that that were
clinically valid i thought and they
except for this this threshold of 90
morphine milligram equivalents so
what does that mean so what was that
threshold that was per day
yes
yeah you're kidding me no
for chronic yeah okay that would be 90
milligrams of morphine or like 60
milligrams
that would be the conversion and then as
as peter alluded to that's a whole other
issue because one mme for me is not one
enemy yeah your metabolism is different
uh your psychology is different so um
and
unfortunately
and this should be a real lesson never
put numbers in guidelines because people
just
grasp them uh and never let go so this
90 milligram morphine milligram yeah
became almost you know um like it was
handed down from mount sinai and uh some
doctors felt they had to
stay uh at that dose which for you know
people without a chronic pain so there's
probably enough but you know there are
folks with chronic pain who need
hundreds of um milligrams or mmes i
should say and um
so
they were either taken down to 90 or
ripped off altogether tapered uh some
doctors tried to do it slowly others uh
like
peter mentioned or will often mention
that they're afraid for their license
and frankly they often have good reason
because the dea can be so aggressive and
um
even when the docs are doing the
perfectly right thing so there's been
untold suffering there's a term called
pain refugee
of people who travel um literally across
the state and across the country
sometimes to find a pain doctor who will
yeah um and they
those pain doctors as you mentioned now
are are blinking uh you know red lights
on the dea's dashboard because they end
up dealing with the most difficult
patients who need the highest doses with
the most intractable pain
and um it's getting more difficult and
more difficult the cdc is now
reformulating those guidelines but um
a source tells me it doesn't look very
promising they don't seem to be changing
it very much we'll see we'll see they're
not approved yet and it could be that
they'll go back to the drawing board and
it'll be more enlightened but it's a
terrible problem um and a lot of it's
due to the media i would say the way
they misrepresented the nature of this
addiction
yeah it's a tricky situation because i
for my experience with being on a
i was on so many medications for so long
i'm not on anything anymore thank god
but i was on a lot and
my experience was that the psychiatric
medications i was on were far more
harmful like um i
for
when i had my hip and ankle replaced i
was on oxycontin way more than 90 mil
like mme's equivalent i think at one
point it was 240 milligrams a day
but i got up there and doctors aren't
informed that like you said people
metabolize things differently so you can
have rapid metabolizers so then the
medication wears off faster for some
people than it does for other people so
i had the issue of
oxycontin every 12 hours but it wore off
at seven hours so i was in withdrawal so
then i had oxycodone to cover the
withdrawal
so eventually that was changed to three
times a day but it was just bouncing in
and out of withdrawal throughout the day
being covered by other pain medications
so i think
people just don't know what they're
doing in regards to pharmaceuticals in
general and it's nice that they're
kind of maybe becoming more aware of the
dangers of psychiatric medications but
rather than just focusing on
specific medications that are more
dangerous like oh all of them which puts
painkillers on the list and then like
you guys are talking about screws over
people who are in chronic pain and when
you're experiencing chronic pain nothing
else matters
you don't like you don't care right it's
like oh i'm gonna have an addiction
did that maybe i won't want to die as
much like
the the upside is so dramatic that
talking to somebody dealing with severe
chronic pain about whether or not
they're going to become dependent on
something is kind of a joke
yeah i have a colleague and i'm happy to
connect your listeners if anyone's
interested he's at the university of
alabama and he's trying to do
uh
kind of the first um objective or highly
quantitative study of people who have
been tapered and frankly have either
thought seriously about suicide or have
followed through there are a lot of
anecdotes but nothing systematic and
he's trying to uh study them so
um maybe i could give um his contact
information and you put it in the show
notes or something yeah sure i'll stick
that in the show notes
yeah that's a good study that's that's a
risk
yeah i think your friend is that dr
cursettes or kirsten i can never
pronounce his name yeah yeah no he's a
he's a fantastic i mean he's a good
scientist he's also a really nice
guy all my interactions have been
extremely positive
you know part of the problem with all
this is
you know some of this doesn't even have
to do directly with pancreas some of
this is the pressure when we you know
with a with obamacare and the move to
push to more
electronic health records we put a lot
more pressure on doctors for their time
use and when they have to see so many
patients during day and they have to
fill out so many forms and put
information they need shortcuts to help
figure out prescribing decisions well
when they do that they they will rely on
something called and you can look this
up um from wired maya holovitz has an
amazing just an incredible article on
this on
pdmps and things like narcscare these
are electronic programs that are
supposed to do
these algorithms we don't know actually
what's in the algorithms we can't
check but these algorithms will
determine if someone is at high risk or
not of abusing an opioid and they will
make decisions on us what we do know on
things that are completely arbitrary if
you are a disabled patient you maybe use
multiple pharmacies or go to multiple
physicians well in this pdmp that will
be a a point against you
and so often when these physicians have
to make they have they have little time
they have to make a gut check maybe this
is the first time they met this patient
and they have to make a decision is this
worth the risk can i trust this person
well if you're in the er especially i
mean
i love er docs but they're crazy cynical
because they see some of the worst of
humanity it's it's hard to make that
decision i have an uncle who's an
amazing guy and he works at a nursing
home unfortunately because he works at a
nursing home and because of his medical
history he's never broken the law he's
never abused drugs he was bro when he
when he went to his doctors like you
have to come in you have to do this and
they brought him in because they want to
chew him out because they suspected him
of abusing drugs now there was no
evidence of said behavior no history of
it but the the these electronic
algorithms were like eh maybe there
might be maybe this is something you
should take a look at and and those are
some of more issues
that take a lot of the uh the autonomy
away from that special provider-patient
relationship
and they're just i mean we could be here
hours talking about all the issues but
those are some of the big things that
popped in my mind
yeah i'm glad you mentioned that you're
so sensitive to the pressures on doctors
look i don't prescribe payments i'm a
psychiatrist um
but um
but
i mean for every story in this situation
there's almost an opposite one in other
words it is true that there are horror
stories of doctors who say frankly
i'm appalled because i can understand
how a doctor who works in a system that
believes you know has decided the cdc
guidelines says everybody has to be down
by 90
i can
see how they feel compelled to do it but
some do it much more sympathetically
than others they try to help the person
find a pain clinic um they they
as i said do it slowly uh they they tell
them they they're so sorry they have to
do this and others frankly seem pretty
insensitive so i guess for almost every
story there's another one doctors never
have enough time with patients and um
and it is also true that patients sell
their meds um that that's just true and
so the level of suspicion when you don't
really have a chance to get to know your
um you know the patient is it's kind of
understandable plus as i said they're
afraid the dea is you know hovering so
boy it is hard to find um
overall it's kind of hard to find
villains the system is awful um but this
again the cdc situation did not help um
one reason i'm a little pessimistic and
i hate to be so is that uh frankly
stefan cortez and i and two other three
other um doctors uh one was a
pharmacologist
wrote to the cdc um in 2019
and we asked them to please clarify
their guidelines because we knew they
didn't mean that patients had to be
ripped off their medications or that if
they were stable on 400 whatever you
were on michaela 250 you know milligrams
of oxygen and doing well or was helping
you leave you alone
um and they did to their credit within a
month of that letter being sent to them
they uh issued a press release saying
this is not what we meant if patients
are doing well you know leave them alone
and then they published an article two
weeks later in the new england journal
of medicine
to that effect and we were so ecstatic
we put we had a little what were called
hp3 health professionals for um pain
patients and um we have a website but it
only has that letter on it because we
were devoted to that one issue and uh we
posted it we told every pain patient
show this to your doctor
and we got so many emails i did show it
to my doctor and he didn't care
yeah boy
yeah
that's tricky
that's really tricky it's like
every time the cdc changes something too
do people read it
like does anybody read these things i
know for
because i was like kind of embroiled in
the whole benzodiazepine
thing that's
a problem to say the least but i know
that they issued a black box warning
last
year but nobody i don't think primary
care
primary physicians actually
know about that stuff because they're so
overworked and they have too many
patients like you said so i don't know
how the information actually gets down
to anybody who's prescribing
well the irony is sometimes it is drug
reps
and um and that is a you know part of
again this the oxycontin story but um
you know were they not i'm sure not all
of them but some of them you know really
did bend
the truth um it is true that a
long-acting medication and oxycontin the
content means continuous any long-acting
medication compared to a short-acting
equivalent is going to be less addictive
because that's just the dynamics of
of pharmacology the slower and
the slower
reinforcing substance gets to your brain
the less addictive potential it can have
well but i thought so can
yeah yeah i thought it was less de i
thought it was more dependence forming
though no
oh that's not the experience i've had at
all oh interesting well yeah or with or
with people on methadone
um
oh yeah they're they're both dependents
forming i know that with the shorter
acting ones you get more of the highs
right right so we get more quickly
yeah yeah the more rewarding it is right
yeah for sure i've just i've talked to a
lot of pain specialists about
painkillers specifically and from what
i've been told it's the ones that are
super long acting because it stays at
such a stable dose for a long time that
people end up on for years because it's
so i see what you're saying yes it can
be harder to get off them yes that's why
we take a year to get people off
methadone but that's also psychosocial
because they they need to prepare for
their
um
you know as i said it just takes a long
time to become an addict a lot of
problems
that preceded it that caused you to turn
to drugs and then you created a whole
set of problems when you were addicted
so it's a lot to work on
um but but from a strict
sort of medical uh standpoint yes it
takes a longer time on the other hand
that makes it somehow self-tapering so
it comes out of your system but it comes
out more slowly so that's all true
um
uh but i wasn't gonna
uh gee i was gonna make my own point i
forgot but
carry on
do you guys um okay so two comments i
guess one
perhaps
because i'm thinking of solutions to
this problem as much fun as it is
talking about how problematic things are
um i know in canada if you're on
painkillers then you can get the
pharmacy to
give you a certain number of doses like
per day or per week so maybe one of the
solutions would be allowing
physicians to give out some of these
pain killers to people in chronic pain a
little bit more easily and have the
pharmacy monitor how many pills they get
something like that do they do that
anything like that in the states
it's annoying but i mean if it allows
people with chronic pain to have access
to painkillers properly it might be a
solution
i admit my understanding of the workings
of
like a pharmacy in different countries
is limited i am aware that canada does
have a lot more flexibility in certain
areas when it comes to
dealing with these substances but i
my knowledge on that area is a little
weak so i can't really speak much to it
i apologize that's okay
do you guys do so
what do you guys see in the future do
you have solutions to the problems or
suggestions for the government about how
to i guess
if we're looking at easing access to
people who
are really really suffering that would
be that's kind of what i'm looking to do
just began only i haven't seen the
downsides as much as the downsides of
being in chronic pain so i haven't seen
you know people who shouldn't
necessarily be on them who are addicted
to them i've been more on the side of
people who really need them and then
can't have them yeah yeah
um is it okay if i go first i was about
to raise my hand i was like i don't know
why i was doing that i was like back in
school
um
it seems to me in american culture we
sometimes can be we're very hard-headed
people and sometimes we are very
monocular thinking part of the problem
is we have two populations of people
with different needs um
that kind of they kind of parallel to
each other
you know about
ten percent in this population and it's
really hard to tell satellite knows this
stuff better than i do
um struggle with drug addiction or using
listed drugs and about you know as of
2019 about 30 million people were
reliant on long-term pain opioid use
these are about populations relatively
the same size and part of the problem is
we have been trying to set these these
groups and their needs against each
other it's this idea that you know we
have to make it really hard on the
patients the pain patients so we can
save the addicts
and that strategy it doesn't work we've
tried it there's now so much evidence
and statistics to show this uh this
attempt to try to punish one population
say the other
will not work and will only make things
worse and we will only be able to figure
out our ways out of this terrible mess
we are able to treat patients with their
physicians
as in independent relationships meet the
needs of those patients
as long as we stay in this mindset that
we we have to treat people like numbers
and we have to uh make decisions that
are above them and their health and
their physicians we will struggle to get
out of this and
addiction is such a difficult thing and
we have so many ideas we need to get
past to try to try to deal with it i
mean i'm not in favor of like everything
in harm reduction but you know
there's a lot of ideas there that are
worth exploring that what we've tried so
far
they don't have the best efficacy i mean
12 steps are cool i've i've had a friend
that really struggled with addiction so
i've been through the 12-step program
it's helpful but if you look at the
statistics of its efficacy it's it's not
very high it's pretty low and you know
even something like many branches
narcotics anonymous they'll have
something like well if you're using
methadone to deal with your problem if
you're you're getting a medicated
assistant treatment to deal with your
addiction well that's that's a moral
failing so we have a lot of ideas and
impulses in our culture and society
we're going to have to need to get past
if we want to get on top of these things
or
just let the timer run out i mean this
is what my friend jacob saul and the guy
at reason has written
i mean for 20 years about drugs and
opioids you know his theorem was okay
well then uh at worst we're going to be
waiting 20 years because that's often
how medical fads go 10 years ago
10 years to go out and at that point
maybe then people will allowed to have
payments again but i mean how many
people will have suffered
needlessly during that time on both
sides of the issue
yeah
yeah
yeah well said
do you can i contribute my
yeah yeah for sure and then i agree with
everything you said um
i have four things so i'll make them
quick um the first is that
medical students and residents just need
far better education or education at all
in in in pain management um
and
and point me you know one
slightly uh
distressing fact about all this is um
true doctors are under a lot of pressure
they always say and it's true it takes
it takes five minutes to prescribe
percocet in 30 minutes not to because
people will
it becomes a struggle and sometimes
you're struggling with someone whose
motivations maybe aren't so great in
other times with someone who desperately
does need it but the point is it takes
longer um but
this medication was schedule two you
know dea has five schedules one is
heroin and lsd
um
uh drugs considered and i emphasize
considered um having no medical value
and then it goes to five like codeine
and then most of the medications we're
talking about are schedule two well that
morphine schedule too i mean i i
you know
come on docs uh first off you shouldn't
be learning from drug reps uh
but
better education that's number one
number two is
maybe i should speak for myself saying
as a clinician
i'm not that much uh bothered by by a
red flag here and there in other words
if i were to practice in a way that
might be
uh you know um
not
a little unconventional i don't mind
somebody actually um saying oh how are
you can you walk through your treatment
you know in a curious and open-minded
and and uh
uh way you know how is it that how can
you uh explain that your your patient is
on this dose or on this medication and
then i say well we've tried everything
else and i read some case studies that
show this can work and we're gonna see
it and they go oh okay fine that makes
it if there was a history and this all
takes time but if there was a history of
this kind of um surveillance with a
small s that was benign i you know i
think doctors would be less terrified
um yeah some kind of scrutiny number
three out of four is i mentioned the cdc
but for heaven's sakes it its initial
guidelines had so much impact hopefully
a sensible revision would too
um and four is for people to realize
we're not in the um for politicians and
and
authorities and i'm afraid to say even
some docs
to realize we're no longer in the pill
phase of the opioid crisis that was
considered the first phase and and
granted it did set a lot of problems in
motion and then it was around 2010
heroin came in in 2014 fentanyl and
fentanyl is what's killing almost
everyone now who's dying um people are
using younger people are actually using
opioids less but the death rate is going
up because fentanyl
times as potent as morphine is what's
killing people
oh i didn't know that so you think we're
over here
sorry go ahead
yeah so opioid use has gone down but
because of how strong fentanyl is there
are more accidental overdoses or is that
a lot of fentanyl mixed with like
something like cocaine or something
some of it is in fact cocaine is not um
typically a particularly deadly drug it
could be a very destructive drug you
know from as we know from crack but um
it's not that it's not known for its
deadliness uh but yes
it is true now it is more far more risky
because fentanyl
is is mixed in with it um i i even wrote
in an article um
uh that i think this i know some people
would find this very controversial but
now we're in a phase where we're coming
into a phase where it could be the
safest time to prescribe opioids because
there's so much um
there's so much attention being paid to
to doing it and the fact that now
hospitals do have more guidelines about
how how physicians should proceed
and um so i think we could enter that
phase if especially if the med if the
education
um aspect of it is fulfilled in medical
schools and residencies um there are
other medications certainly that can
help physical therapy is underrated it
can really work when you stick with it
um
other things psychotherapy can matter so
not not did your mother you know um
not that kind of historical
psychotherapy getting into old conflict
kind of thing but how to a cognitive
behavioral therapy because anxiety
really makes pain so much worse point is
there are other things and it could well
be that that a lot of people on
high-dose
opioids today didn't have to be on that
higher dose if these other interventions
were implemented that's all true but
once you're on the high dose and if it's
working and you want to stay on it to me
it's unconscionable that doctors would
take you off
yes
okay
um
you go ahead we're probably getting near
time to go but i just want to add two
things if that's okay one i definitely
felt like needed to be said the first is
um yeah if you're relying on any illicit
drugs off the black market you have to
be extremely careful
many people i know that still can
persist in
using make sure they get a fentanyl test
kit which aren't legal in all 50 states
it's a big enough problem i have i know
two people um in the media one is a
reporter down here in south dakota
another is eric bowling whose kids died
or overdosed from fentanyl not because
they were taking a substance they
thought was a drug to get high but it
was taking something like what they
thought was adderall this is just some
kid gives it to them they think it's
eternal maybe they'll help them with
their tests what they don't know is that
it's been laced with
and it takes them out and that's
unfortunately um a
a terrible story that is in some cases
common and the other thing is you know
to pain patients or anyone that's
listening you know that feels really
hopeless right now this is always my
worry every time i talk or write about
this stuff is that i'm i'm pushing
people down um there is hope i mean
michaela here herself you know evidence
of her what i've been through you know
you never know what's going to come up
tomorrow you never know what options are
going to be in the future
um something you know something one of
these options that you try that you
think might not work might actually help
some and you know this isn't going to be
forever and lastly you know
it behooves us who are disabled people
that we try to hold on we need to have
our story um told for history for the
record for our families and friends so
to help society not to repeat this
because our lives are worth living so i
know the temptation for suicidality and
self-harm is so high right now in the
chronic pain community high enough that
i there are many times i try to talk
about this and ask people maybe not
promote euthanasia and there's like a
ton of pushback how could you say that
um really try hold on do your best you
know i thought when i lost my medication
that was it game over
but i didn't i didn't uh click the game
over button i continued on and things
changed up and i bought my life is a
difficult one it is much better than it
was in 2018 and it's interesting so
there is hope so if you are struggling
with these issues or your loved one is
you know please hold on um things can
get better
we can get through this this this
craziness will not be forever so just
please hold on
yes
that was good
i would say going back to what you said
um that
that a fentanyl mixed in with ritalin or
adderall that's scary i didn't know that
that was happening but it might be worth
if people are listening or know of
people who are like you said getting
these black market drugs having a
naloxone kit if they're available is
also probably a good idea just to
counteract potential overdoses and
that's i don't i don't know about
america but in canada it's it's either
twenty dollars or it's free it comes
from drug stores
it's free so you can just have one in a
cupboard somewhere just in case if you
know of people who are doing that
because this fentanyl problem is a real
problem
yeah okay
peter and sally
let's start with sally where can people
find you online if they want to learn
more about what you do
uh well i have a website which is sally
satellmd.com com
sallysattlemd.com
and um if people want to reach me
through twitter it's
s-l-s-a-t-e-l-s-l-s-a-t-e-l
perfect peter
oh i'm i'm freelance i'm all over the
place you can usually find some my own
reporting at the happy warrior sub stack
um you can also find my work i i'm
pretty frequent um and available on
twitter which is happy warrior p
um feel free to send me a line or if you
have queries questions questions
comments just want uh someone shoulder
to cry on whatever that's how we met
i've done it all
ah
well thanks guys hopefully that shines a
light on this
opioid problem that we're experiencing
and hopefully things get better but
thank you both for coming on thank you
for the opportunity no thank you this
was great
[Music]
you